>>> SO I REALLY WANT YOU TO TAKE
TH ALL IN, OKAY?
WATCH TH.
A MICHIGAN LAWMAKER TAKING ON
TOXIC AND BASELESS POLITICAL
SMEARS AGAINST HER IN A FIERY
SPEECH TODAY AND TALKING ABOUT
STATE SENATOR MALLORY RESPONDING
AFTER HER COLLEAGUE FELLOW STATE
SENATOR LANA TICE SENT A
FUNDRAISING EMAIL ACCUSING HER
OF WANTING HER TO GROOM AND
SEXUALIZE KINDERGARTNERS AND
CLAIMING SHE WANTED TO TEACH
8-YEAR-OLDS THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR SLAVERY.
NONE OF THAT IS TRUE.
THE SENATOR COULD HAVE FOUND HER
WAY INTO A POLITICAL GUTTER
RESPONDING TO THAT, INSTEAD,
THIS IS WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY.
>> SO I SAT ON IT FOR AWHILE
WONDERING WHY ME?
AND THEN I REALIZED BECAUSE I AM
THE BIGGEST THREAT TO YOUR
HOLLOW HATEFUL SCHEME BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T CLAIM THAT YOU ARE
TARGETING MARGINALIZED KIDS IN
THE NAME OF QUOTE PARENTAL
RIGHTS IF ANOTHER PARENT IS
STANDING UP TO SAY NO.
SO THEN WHAT?
THEN YOU DEHUMANIZE AND
MARGINALIZE ME.
YOU SAY THAT I'M ONE OF THEM.
YOU SAY SHE'S A GROOMER.
SHE SUPPORTS PEDOPHILES AND
WANTS CHILDREN TO BELIEVE
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR SLAVERY
AND TO FEEL BAD ABOUT THEMSELVES
BECAUSE THEY'RE WHITE.
SO WHO I AM?
I AM A STRAIGHT WHITE CHRISTIAN
MARRY S SUBURBAN MOM THAT KNOWST
SOMEHOW MEANS CHILDREN ARE BEING
TAUGHT TO FEEL BAD OR HATE
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY'RE WHITE
IS ABSOLUTELY NON-SENSE.
NO CHILD ALIVE TODAY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SLAVERY.
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SLAVERY BUT EACH
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US BEARS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WRITING THE
NEXT CHAPTER OF HISTORY.
EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
DECIDES WHAT HAPPENS NEXT AND
HOW WE RESPOND TO HISTORY AND
THE WORLD AROUND US.
WE ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PAST.
WE ALSO CANNOT CHANGE THE PAST.
WE CAN'T PRETEND IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN OR DENY PEOPLE THEIR VERY
RIGHT TO EXIST.
I AM A STRAIGHT WHITE CHRISTIAN
MARRIED SUBURBAN MOM.
I WANT MY DAUGHTER TO KNOW SHE'S
LOVED, SUPPORTED AND SEEN FOR
WHOEVER SHE BECOMES.
I WANT HER TO BE CURIOUS,
EMPATHETIC AND KIND.
I WANT EVERY CHILD IN THIS STATE
TO FEEL SEEN, HEARD AND
SUPPORTED, NOT MARGINALIZED AND
TARGETED BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
STRAIGHT, WHITE AND CHRISTIAN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NOW MALLORY, THANK YOU.
IT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN SAID
BETTER.
THERE SHE IS LIVE.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED, OUR TEAM
REACHED OUT TO STATE SENATOR
TICE FOR A STATEMENT.
ISN'T HEARD BACK.
LET GET INTO THIS CONVERSATION.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORDS.
WHAT A SPEECH.
WHY WAS IT SO IMPORTANT TO
RESPOND TO THE TOTALLY
OUTRAGE
ACCUSATIONS BY YOUR COLLEAGUE?
>> WHATEVER I FELT IN THE MOMENT
WHERE SHE ACCUSED ME OF GROOMING
AND PEDOPHILE AND ALL THE THINGS
SHE SAID TO ME PAILS IN
COMPARISON TO BE A TRANS KID
THAT WANTS TO PLAY SOCCER AND
SOCIETY SAYS YOU'RE WRONG AND
BROKEN OR A MONSTER OR A BLACK
KID IN SCHOOL TRYING TO PUSH
OUT BASIC HISTORY AND AN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THIS COUNTRY
IS BUILT ON.
I HAD TO SAY SOMETHING.
>> THIS IS NOT NORMAL.
THIS IS NOT POLITICAL.
THIS IS JUST RIDICULOUSNESS AND
PEOPLE WILL ACCUSE YOU OR ACCUSE
ME JUST FOR CALLING OUT THE
RIDICULOUSNESS OF THIS AS BEING
SOMEHOW LIBERAL LEFTIES.
IS THIS WHAT REPUBLICANS WANT TO
BE, PEOPLE JUST ACCUSING PEOPLE,
ACCUSATIONS OF GROOMING AND
PEDOPHILES.
THIS IS A MAIN STREAM TOXIC
POLITICAL TOOL IN THE JUST THE
LAST FEW WEEKS.
THERE ARE REAL WORLD
CONSEQUENCES TO THE BASELESS
CHARGES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS WHAT THEY
WANT TO BE, THIS IS WHAT THEY
ARE NOW.
THIS IS THE SAME TYPE OF FEAR
MONGERING AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THAT CAME OUT OF QANON
WHERE THE BELIEF IS THAT THERE
IS A SATAN KABUL OF PEDOPHILES
RUNNING THE COUNTRY AND NOW THAT
IS THE MAIN STREAM.
WE HAVE A MAJOR POLITICAL PARTY
TAKING THIS MESSAGING AND USING
IT TO TARGET MARGINALIZED KIDS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE RIGHT NOW
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE IT STOP.
>> YOU ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
MANUFACTURED OUTRAGE OVER
CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND SLAVERY
BEING TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS AND YOU
TALKED ABOUT IT BASED ON YOUR
OWN EXPERIENCE AS A PARENT.
EXPLAIN THAT.
>> I AM FRANKLY TIRED OF
REPUBLICANS CLAIMING THAT THEY
SPEAK FOR SUBURBAN MOMS, RIGHT?
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO BRING BACK
VOTES AND I'LL BE UP FRONT.
IT WAS WHITE WOMEN LIKE ME THAT
ELECTED DONALD TRUMP INTO OFFICE
AND SUPPORTED HOW WE GOT HERE
AND I KNOW THAT THEY DO NOT
SPEAK FOR ME AND THEY DO NOT
SPEAK FOR MANY OF US, AND WE
HAVE TO STAND UP TOGETHER AND
SAY NO, THIS ISN'T WHO WE ARE.
THIS ISN'T WHAT WE STAND FOR AND
WANT FOR OUR KIDS.
>> YOUR SPEECH WAS VERY POWERFUL
BUT THESE KINDS OF ATTACKS WON'T
GO AWAY OVERNIGHT.
HOW WILL YOU CONTINUE TO BLUNT
THESE SUPER POTENT POLITICAL
TACTICS BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT WANT TO BELIEVE
THIS GARBAGE?
IT'S JUST GARBAGE?
>> THEY DO.
PART OF THE POINT I WANTED TO
MAKE IN THE SPEECH IS THAT
PEOPLE LIKE SENATOR TICE ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF HER OWN
SUPPORTERS BY LYING TO THEM AND
TRYING TO CONVINCE PEOPLE ALL OF
THE PROBLEMS IN YOUR LIVES WITH
YOUR COST OF HEALTH CARE, THE
ROADS OR PRICES AT THE GAS PUMP
THAT IT IS SOMEHOW SOMEBODY
ELSE'S FAULT THAT IF YOU CAN
REDIRECT YOUR HATRED AND ANGER
THAT THAT WILL FIX IT AND IT'S
NOT.
>> GRIEVANCE.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO DO.
IT IS.
AND IF TOMORROW A TRANS KID
WASN'T ALLOWED TO PLAY SOCCER,
THAT WOULDN'T MAKE PEOPLE'S
LIVES ANY BETTER.
>> THANK YOU, SENATOR.
APPRECIATE IT.
I REALLY DO.
>> THANK YOU, DON.
>> YOUR MESSAGE IS VERY
POWERFUL.
THERE SHOULD BE MORE FOLKS LIKE
YOU AND DAMMIT, THIS IS NOT
POLITICAL OR LEFT OR RIGHT.
IT ASININE.
IT STUPID AND CRAZY AND VERY
DANGEROUS.
>> THAT'S MY HOPE.
WE NEED A LOT MORE PEOPLE LIKE
ME TO SAY HATE WON'T WIN.
>> THE NEWS MEDIA NEEDS TO DO
IT, AS WELL AND NOT BE AFRAID OF
BEING CALLED NAMES OR BIAS OR
LIBERAL OR WHAT HAVE YOU BECAUSE
IT'S JUST PLAIN OLD WRONG.
SO TO MY COLLEAGUES OUT THERE,
DO THE SAME THIN